[موسيقى]
طبعا كلكم عارفين منظمه اوبك اكبر وانجح
في العالم تقريبا 13 دوله في ثلاث قارات
مختلفه بتسيطر على 30% من انتاج النفط
العالمي وتمانين في الميه من احتياطياته
علشان كده لو سالتكم هل ممكن نلاقي دوله
واحده في العالم بتمتلك نفوس زي اوبك على
سلع حيويه زي النفط كده غالبا اجاباتكم
هتكون في صوت واحد مستحيل لكن الاجابه دي
مش صح احنا عندنا دوله واحده بس في العالم
الدوله دي عربيه بتملك نفوس يعادل تقريبا
نفوس دول اوبك مجتمعه على مورد لا تقل
اهميته عن النفط ومش هنبالغ لو قلنا انه
هيكون اكثر اهميه في المستقبل الدوله دي
هي المغرب الشقيق والسلعه هي الفوسفات زي
ما بنسميه في المشرق العربي او الفوسفات
زي ما بيسموه اخوانا المغاربه المغرب يا
اخواننا بتسيطر لوحدها على 70 ل 75% من
احتياطيات الفوسفات على مستوى العالم يعني
نسبه قريبه جدا من احتياطيات دول اوبك
مجتمعه من النفط انا كلمتكم قبل كده في
حلقات مختلفه عن اهميه المعادن والثروات
المعدنيه والصراع العالمي حواليها لكن
الكلام عن الفوسفات لمستوى تاني خالص من
الاهميه وفي معلومات هتستغربوا جدا منها
فايه حكايه الفوسفات بالضبط وليه لعالم
اتغير لما اكتشفه وامتى ادرك المغرب الكنز
الضخم الموجود في اراضيه وازاي استغله
وايه دور المغرب ومكانته في سوق الفوسفات
العالمي وسوق الاسمده حاليا وهل بيستفيد
بما يكفي من الثروه دي والفوائد دي ماليه
واقتصاديه بس ولا اكبر من كده وازاي متوقع
ان الفوسفات يغير وضع المغرب بشكل جذري في
المستقبل دي عينه من الاسئله المثيره جدا
اللي هندردش حواليها في حلقه النهارده بس
قبل ما نبدا بفكركم بالاشتراك في القناه
لان اشتراككم مهم جدا لتطوير المحتوى
بتاعنا بفكركم برضو ان كل حلقاتنا اللي
فاتت مترجمه للغه الانجليزيه فما تنسوش
تشتركوها مع اصحابكم الاجانب تعرفوهم
علينا انا اشرف ابراهيم المخ بال اقتصادي
[موسيقى]
عايز اشكر شركه العالميه لرعايتها الحلقه
دي وهي شركه عندها خبره طويله في الاسواق
الماليه بحجم تداولات شهريه تجاوز الاتنين
تريليون دولار ليه بنصح بالتعامل مع اكس
علشان اربع مميزات الاولى انها مرخصه
ومراقبه من هيئات رقبيه التانيه بعرف اسحب
فلوسي فيها بشكل فوري بدون تدخل بشري
الثالثه ان عملتهم منخفضه الرابعه ان
التداول بيتنفس بسرعه تقدر تفتح حساب
اسلامي لا محدود وتبدا تشتري وتبيع الاسهم
والدهب هتلاقوا لينك لهم تحت الفيديو وفي
تعليقات فيسبوك قبل ما نبدا نشرح قصه
الفوسفات المغربي محتاجين نعرف ايه هو
معدن الفوسفات اساسا بصوا يا جماعه في
تشابه في بعض الصفات بين الفوسفات والنفط
يعني الفوسفات زيه زي النفط مورد حيوي
موجود بكميه محدوده في الارض المعدن ده
اتركز على مدار ملايين السنين في انواع
بعينها من الصخور اسمها صخور الفوسفات وفي
اللحظه اللي هنستهلك فيها كل صخور
الفوسفات في العالم
هكون عندنا ساعتها على الارجح اي طريقه
لانتاجه صناعيه لكن الفوسفات اخطر من
النفط لانه حتى الان ما لوش بديل على عكس
النفط اللي ممكن استبداله مثلا بالغاز
الطبيعي او مصادر الطاقه المتجدده وغيرها
حتى لو بتكلفه اكبر وبطريقه اصعب طب ليه
وجود الفوسفات مهم وحيوي كده لانه بدون
الفوسفات وصناعه الاسمده المبنيه عليه
جايز انا وانت ما كناش نبقى موجودين
دلوقتي وده لاننا بنتكلم على عنصر هو اساس
الطفره الهائله في عدد سكان العالم خلال
100 سنه اللي فاتوا لازم تفهموا انه خلال
القرن اللي فات ده بس عدد سكان العالم
ارتفع من 1.9 مليار نسمه لاكثر من 8 مليار
حاليا يعني اكتر من سته مليار في قرن واحد
بس الرقم ده مستحيل كنا نوصله بدون
الزياده الكبيره في المحاصيل اللي وفرتها
صناعه الاسمده القائمه بالاساس على تلات
عناصر رئيسيه اهمهم الفوسفات يعني من غير
الفوسفات والعناصر لطفره صناعه الاسمده ما
كناش هنعرف ننتج غذاء يكفي البشر
الموجودين في العالم حاليا وفي المستقبل
اهو الفوسفات اللي المفروض بياكل العالم
ده كله المغرب عنده منه احتياطيات تقدر
باكتر من 50 مليار طن وده اكبر احتياطي
عالمي بفارق مرعب عن اي دوله تانيه يكفي
اقول لكم ان الصين صاحبه المركز الثاني
احتياطياتها منه 3.2 مليار طن بس ولاني
بكين عارفه ان الاحتياطيات دي مش هتكون
كافيه لتلبيه احتياجاتها في المستقبل قريب
اخذت قرار بحظر تصدير الفوسفات المستخرج
من اراضيها بشكل نهائي طب امتى كانت
البدايه خلونا نرجع بالزمن اكتر من قرن
وتحديدا سنه 1910 لما اتنين من علماء
الكيمياء الالمان هم فريدس هابر كارل بوش
اعلنوا اكتشاف تفاعل هبر بوش شهير لتصنيع
الامونيا من الهيدروجين والنيتروجين وده
الكشف اللي فتح الباب لصناعه الاسمده
الضخمه اللي غيرت العالم اللي نعرفه بفضل
الصناعه دي كتير من الدول الغربيه تحولت
من دول فقيره زراعيا بتعاني علشان توفر
الغذاء لشعوبها لدول مزدهره عندها فائض في
انتاج الغذاء مش بس كده ده حتى الدول اللي
كان مناخها غير مناسب للزراعه تماما زي
الدول البارده جدا في شمال اوروبا زي
النرويج مثلا امتلكت القدره على زراعه بعض
المحاصيل باختصار كده الدنيا كانت ماشيه
زي الحلاوه لحد ما بدانا نسمع جرس انذار
بينبهنا ان عصر الطفره الغذائيه الكبيره
اللي حققتها الاسمده ممكن ينتهي في اي
لحظه ايه بقى اللي حصل باختصار العالم
اكتشف الاسمده المعدنيه اللي هي البديل
السحري للاسمده العضويه او الطبيعيه اسمده
قائمه هي كمان على عناصر ومعادن غير
متجدده يعني برده ممكن تخلص في اي وقت
الكلام هنا عن 3 عناصر رئيسيه بتتحكم في
صناعه الاسمده وهي البوتاسيوم والفوسفات
والنيتروجين والبوتاسيوم والفوسفات تحديدا
ممكن ينتهوا خلال بعض مئات من السنين في
افضل الاحوال الفوسفات بيبقى موجود في
صوره حجر صخري بيتم معالجته لانتاج ماده
خامس اكسيد الفسفور المكون الرئيسي لصناعه
الاسمده غير حمض الفوسفوريك اللي بيدخل هو
كمان في صناعات كتير اهمها صناعه
الالكترونيات صناعه تعدين الفوسفات
العالميه بدات تقريبا سنه 1920 ودي هي نفس
السنه اللي تاسست فيها شركه الفوسفات
المغربيه العملاقه المملوكه للدوله
والمعروفه باسم المكتب الشريف للفوسفاط
المكتب الشريف بدا انشطه لاستخراج سنه
1921 في منطقه خريبكه مباشره بدا في تصدير
انتاجه عبر ميناء الدار البيضاء في نفس
السنه تقريبا وفي سنه 1931 وسعت الشركه
نشاطها وبدات في استخراج الفوسفات من
منطقه اليوسفيه لحد الوقت ده كان دور
المغرب بيقتصر على استخراج الفوسفات الخام
لدول تانيه في كل انحاء العالم الدول دي
كانت بتتولى عمليات المعالجه ثم تصنيع
المنتج النهائي اللي هو الاسمده بدون اي
دور للمغرب تقريبا في العمليه دي استمر
الوضع كده تقريبا لحد سنه 1965 يعني بعد
اقل من عقد على استقلال المغرب لما
المملكه قررت انشاء اول موقع للمعالجه في
مدينه اسفي بعدها في سنه 1976 الشركه
اطلقت موقع استخراج تالت في بنجرير وبعده
منشاه معالجه تانيه في الجرف الاصفر سنه
1984 استمر تطور الوضع بشكل تدريجي لكن
بطيء شويه لحد ازمه الغذاء العالميه
الكبيره بين 2006 و2008 واللي لفتت نظر
العالم كله لمشكله تناقص امدادات الغذاء
وقله المحاصيل الزراعيه ومعها بدات
الانظار تتركز على العناصر المستخدمه في
صناعه الاسمده واهمها الفوسفات وده خلى
اسعار الاسمده ومعها خام الفوسفات ترتفع
بشكل كبير جدا
سياده انتاج المملكه السنوي من الفوسفات
بمعدل الضعف تقريبا مقارنه بسنه 2008 في
حين ان انتاجها من الاسمده تضاعف ثلاث
مرات وفي الوقت الحالي مركز الاسمده
المغربيه في جرف الاصفر بينتج تقريبا 45
مزيج مختلف من الاسمده لاغراض التصدير
بتروح لمعظم دول العالم تقريبا خليني اقول
لكم كمان ان سنه 2020 شركه اوسي بي انتجت
حوالي 41 مليون طن من الفوسفات مصنعه
حوالي سبعه مليون طن من حمض الفوسفوريك
الماده الكيميائيه الرئيسيه المستخدمه في
صناعه الاسمده والاهم انها انتجت 11.7
مليون طن من الاسمده الفسفوريه منها حوالي
11 مليون طن تم تصديرها للخارج طبعا احنا
هنا بنستخدم بيانات 2020 لان دي البيانات
الادق لحد قبل انتشار وباء كوفي 19 اللي
اثر على العالم كله والارقام اللي قدمتها
البيانات دي حولت او سي بي للاعب عالمي
حقيقي بدون مبالغه وده لان الشركه ساعدت
العديد من الدول في خمس قارات في الحفاظ
على امدادات غذائيه مستقره في افريقيا
مثلا هنلاقي شركه اوسي بي بتسيطر على 54%
من سوق الفوسفات ومنتجاته في القاره في
حين ان حصتها في اوروبا هي 41% في امريكا
الجنوبيه 46% وبسبب وجودها الكبير في
الهند الشركه المغربيه بتملك 32% من السوق
في جنوب اسيا مش بس كده الشركه كمان
احتفظت بحصه 28% من السوق في امريكا
الشماليه رغم المنافسه مع شركات كبيره زي
شركه موزاييك العملاقه متخصصه في تعدين
الفوسفات والبوتاس وده دفع وزاره التجاره
الامريكيه لفرض تعريفات جمركيه على وردات
الشركه المغربيه سنه 2021 تحت زريعه حمايه
الصناعه المحليه دلوقتي واللي اكيد كتير
من حضراتكم عاوزين يسالوا عنه هو ازاي
الاقتصاد المغربي نفسه استفاد من ده في
الحقيقه هو استفاد كتير جدا وهوضح لكم
دلوقتي فركزوا معي وفقا للبيانات الرسميه
للسنه اللي فاتت 2022 ايرادات مجموعه اوسي
بي تجاوزت 11.2 مليار دولار بارتفاع 36%
عن العامل اللي قبله اللي كانت الايرادات
فيه 8.2 مليار دولار وبزياده ميه في الميه
تقريبا عن سنه 2020 اللي كانت الايرادات
فيها اقل من 6 مليار دولار السبب الرئيسي
لطفره الايرادات الضخمه هي الارتفاع
الكبير في اسعار الاسمده واللي بلغت
ذروتها تقريبا في النصف الاول من 2022
بسبب ازمه الطاقه في اوروبا ثم بسبب
تداعيات الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه الارقام
دي خلت قطاع الفوسفات اكبر القطاعات
المصدره في المغرب بالتفوق على قطاع
السيارات المغربي المزدحر كل عملنا عنه
حلقه مهمه جدا ممكن تشوفوها من هنا ده غير
كونوا من اكبر جهات التوظيف في البلد
بواقع 21,000 وظيفه تقريبا لكن الفوائد
الاقتصاديه المباشره دي هتفضل محدوده جدا
مقارنه بالفوائد غير البشره اللي ممكن
نسميه مجازا دبلوماسيه الفوسفات المغربيه
اللي مش بس بتجلب منافع اقتصاديه طويله
الامد لرباط ولكن كمان بتعزز حضورها
ونفوزها في مناطق كتير في العالم اهمها
قاره افريقيا افريقيا زي ما حضراتكم
عارفين قاره زراعيه بالاساس الزراعه
مسؤوله عن 30% من ناتجها المحلي الاجمالي
وبتوظف 55% من القوى العامله تقريبا
وبتمتلك 65% من الاراضي الصالحه للزراعه
على كوكب الارض وده معناه مش بس من ازدهار
القاره معتمد تماما على النهوض بقطعها
الزراعي وانما معناه كمان ان القطاع ده
حيوي جدا للامن الغذائي العالمي علشان كده
شركه اوسي بي انشات سنه 2016 فرع خاص باسم
او سي بي افريكا علشان يركز بس على تطوير
الزراعه في افريقيا القسم ده حاليا عنده
12 اداره فرعيه في 12 دوله افريقيه
بيركزوا على تطوير الانظمه الزراعيه في
القاره الفرع الافريقي ده اطلق سنه 2016
برنامج ضخم جدا اسمه اجرب بوستر بهدف
توفير خدمات التعليم والتدريب وتحسين
استخدام البذور والاسمده وكمان تسهيل
الامور الماليه للمزارعين الافارقه
البرنامج ده بدا في غانا على سبيل التجربه
وتوسع بعد كده الاكبر اربع اقساطات في غرب
افريقيا وهي نيجيريا وغانا وكوت ديفوار
والسنغال واستفاد منه اكتر من 630 الف
مزارع لحد نهايه سنه 2021 وده ادى لزيادات
كبيره في غله المحاصيل من كل الانواع بما
في ذلك زياده بنسبه 48% في محصول الدره في
نيجيريا و 63% في محصول الدخنه في السنغال
الحقيقه احنا محتاجين نركز جدا مع ثلاث
نماذج بس علشان ندرك حجم النفوس اللي
حققوا المغرب في افريقيا بفضل صناعه
الفوسفات خلونا نبدا معانا نيجيريا اكبر
دوله افريقيه كعدد سكان وواقع 221 مليون
نسمه والشريك الافريقي الاهم المغرب واللي
هنلاقي شركه اوسي بي بتوفر لها اكتر من
90% من الطلب السنوي على الاسمده هناك في
سنه 2018
وقعت مع هيئه الاستثمار السياده النيجيري
بروتوكول لانشاء مصنع للامونيا والاسمده
بقيمه واحد فاصل اربعه مليار دولار بهدف
تعزيز امدادات الاسمده النيجيريا المصنع
الواقع في ولايه نيجيريه الغنيه بالغاز
واللي المفترض يبدا انتاجه سنه 2025 هيقوم
بتصدير 70% من انتاجهم الامونيا لمجمع
جورف الاصفر المغربي في حين ان الاو سي بي
هتورط في المقابل حامض الفسفوريك الناتج
عن المعالجه استخدامه مع ما تبقى من
الامونيا في نيجيريا لانتاج مليون طن
سنويا من اسمنت النيتروجين والفسفور
والبوتاسيوم للسوق المحلي النيجيري
الشراكه مع نيجيريا تحديدا مهمه جدا
للمغرب لانها بتمتلك اكبر احتياطيات غاز
طبيعي في افريقيا بواقع اكثر من 200
تريليون قدم مكعب
النيجيريه دي مش بس مهمه لطموحات المغرب
يتحول لمركز اقليمي للغاز والحجر الزاويه
فيها خط الغاز المغربي النيجير المقترح
لكنها كمان مهمه لاستكمال عمليات تصنيع
الاسماده وده لان الغاز هو اللي بيوفر
الامونيا او النيتروجين وده واحد من
المكونات الاساسيه لتصنيع الاسمده خلونا
نطلع من نيجيريا ونروح لغانا اللي شركه
اوسي بي افريكا استثمرت فيها مبلغ 1.3
مليار دولار لبناء مصنع للاسمده بقدره
مليون طن سنويا زيها زي نيجيريا غنى دوله
غنيه بالغاز الطبيعي لكن الفارق ان عدد
سكان غانا واللي هم حوالي 32 مليون نسمه
اقل بكتير من عدد سكان نيجيريا وده معناه
ان المصنع ده هيوجه انتاجه لاسواق التصدير
في غرب القاره تحديدا دول زي غينيا
والنيجر وساحل العاج وغيرهم وده يخليني
اروح لمحطتنا الثالثه والاخيره في شرق
افريقيا وهي اثيوبيا في سنه 2012 شركه
اوسي بي
[موسيقى]
مليون شخص وجه مخاطر الجوع ده تقريبا اكتر
من عشر سكان العالم وقتها منهم 282 مليون
شخص في افريقيا بس ده معناه ان مساله
انتاج الغذاء بقت مصريه في كتير من دول
العالم وده بيوفر فرص ضخمه لصناعه
الفوسفات المغربيه طيب هل معنى الكلام ده
ان سكه المغاربه سالكه للسيطره على صناعه
الاسمده والزراعه العالميه وما فيش اي
عقبات في الموضوع الاجابه الطريق سالك في
معظمه لكن في عقبات اهمها ان صناعه
الاسمده هي صناعه كثيفه الاستهلاك للطاقه
والمياه المشكله الاكبر هنا هي النيتروجيه
وده لان الاسمده الاكثر انتشارا بتتكون من
مزيج من الفوسفات والنيتروجين او الامونيا
في الوقت الحالي في المصدر الرئيسي
للنيتروجين او الامونيا هو الغاز الطبيعي
وده بيخلي اسعار الغاز متحكم رئيسي في
صناعه الاسمده يعني في نوفمبر 2021 مثلا
تسبب لارتفاع الكبير في اسعار الغاز
الطبيعي في ارتفاع تكلفه انتاج الامونيا
وصولا لالف دولار للطن مقارنه ب 110 دولار
في بدايه نفس السنه والنتيجه لده سعر
ثنائي فوسفات الامونيوم وصل لاعلى مستوى
له من عشر سنين الكلام ده بيفسر بوضوح
مسائل مغرب لتحويل نفسها لمركز العبور
الغزل الافريقي خاصه لما نعرف ان اوسي بي
بتستورد ما بين واحد ونص واتنين مليون طن
من الامونيا سنويه لكن الحقيقه في بديل
قوي جدا بدا يظهر على الساحه للقصه دي
والمغاربه بداوا يبصوا له بجديه كبيره
مؤخرا وهو الامونيا الخضراء ايه حكايه
الامونيا الخضراء دي ببساطه كده بدل ما
المغرب بتستورد اطنان من الامونيا
الرماديه المستخرجه من الغاز الطبيعي فهو
هيصنع الامونيا من الهيدروجين الاخضر
المصنع من موارد الطاقه المتجدده المحليه
في سنه 2018 شركه اوس بي وقعت اتفاقيه مع
معهد الالماني اكبر معهد لابحاث العلوم
التطبيقيه في اوروبا لتطوير مشروع تصنيع
الهيدروجين الاخضر في بن جرير الشراكه مع
المعهد المغربي لابحاث الطاقه الشمسيه
والطاقات الجديده المفترض ان الطاقه
الاوليه للمصنع ده في مرحله التجريب هتكون
1460 طن من الامونيا الخضراء سنويه مع خطط
لزيادتها لحوالي 600 الف طن سنويا بهدف
تلبيه الاحتياجات المحليه وكمان التصدير
للاسواق الاوروبيه بعد كده بسنتين تحديدا
في يونيو 2020 وقع المغرب اتفاقيه مع
المانيا لانشاء اول مصنع افريقي لانتاج
الهيدروجين الاخضر باستخدام البنيه
التحتيه للطاقه الشمسيه المغربيه بموجب
الاتفاق ده الوكاله المغربيه للطاقه
الشمسيه هتقوم بتشيب منشاه لانتاج
الهيدروجين الاخضر بطاقه 10,000 طن سنويا
بتمويل من بنك التنميه الالماني المشروعين
دول على ضخامتهم وجهه عقبات وانقطاعات
الفتره اللي فاتت بسبب بعض الخلافات
السياسيه العلاقه بين الرباط وبالليل لكن
ده ما منعش المغاربه يكملوا في الاتجاه
نفسه في يوليو 2021
اعلن المغرب اطلاق مشروعي مروكو لانتاج
183 الف طن من الامونيا الخضراء سنويا
محلول سنه 2026 بالشراكه مع فيجن فيول
لتنقيه الهيدروجين ومقرها ايرلندا في خضم
كل التطور ده فلازم نشير الى ان مسؤول
المغرب مش راضيين عن قطاع التعدين عموما
اللي معظم ارباحه نمو الفوسفات وبيسعوا
حاليا لتطويره وتحويله لرافعه للاقتصاد
المغربي بالكامل واكتشاف الثروات الطبيعيه
غير الفوسفات هناك ورغم ان ارباح مجموعه
او سي بي في الربع الاول من العام الحالي
2023 واللي كانت 1.7 مليار دولار انخفضت
عن ارباح نفس الفتره من السنه اللي فاتت
اللي كانت 2.6 مليار دولار في اسباب واضحه
للانخفاض ده في ظل ظروف السوق العالمي
الصعبه منها انخفاض اسعار المواد الخام
وتاجيل معظم المشترين لطلبات الشراء على
امل انخفاض الاسعار بشكل اكبر لكن الراجح
ان المجموعه هتعمل اداء اقوى وارباح اكبر
في الربع التاني اللي على وشك الانتهاء من
السنه دي ان شاء الله مش هطول عليكم اكتر
من كده كل تمنياتنا بالتوفيق للمغرب
الشقيق وانه يستثمر موارد الطبيعيه وعلى
راسها الفوسفات بافضل شكل ممكن يعود
بالنفع على الشعب المغربي وعلى العالم
عموما وكل امنياتنا بالتوفيق لمصر ولجميع
الدول العربيه لحد هنا انا خلصت كلامي
وكالعاده عندي سؤال لحضرتكم هل في دوله
عربيه عندها مورد غير النفط والفوسفات
عرفونا ايه هي في التعليقات اقترحوا علينا
لو حبينا نعمل عنها حلقه هتابع اجاباتكم
كلها في التعليقات اللي عايز يشتري اسهم
او ذهب ما تنسوش تشوفوا شركه اكسنس
هتلاقوا رابط تحت الفيديو ما تنسوش
تشتركوا في القناه زي ما اتفقنا ويا ريت
لو عجبتكم الحلقه تعملوا لايك وشير
للفيديو واهم حاجه تحكوا لاصحابكم
وحبايبكم عننا يمكن يستفيدوا سلام
[موسيقى]